good morning John today I'm gonna talk
about numbers numbers are great because
we can't really understand the world
it's too big there is for example no way
for me to really understand what a
million of something is to I got to to
is just one thing twice but two million
house has an example I know how long a
second is and I know how many a million
is is just a thousand thousands and a
thousand is just ten hundreds I can I
can say those words and so then I should
be able to know how long it was a
million seconds ago but I can't I have
no idea I could be a week ago it could
be a month ago it could be a year ago
that let's do a side of experiment right
now everybody write in the comment box
no math allowed no Google searches how
long ago you think it was a million
seconds ago like how many days or months
or years you think it was now I'm gonna
look it up I'm gonna tell you the answer
it was the Monday before last a million
seconds ago interestingly a billion also
a big number billion seconds ago it was
not like last month it was not last year
it was 1982 so by going from million to
billion we went from the Monday before
last to like Michael Jackson's Thriller
and ET and the Falklands War a billion
to a trillion seconds ago were going
from 1982 to 31,000 years ago when
humans were first being introduced to
Europe hello it is nice to meet you
Europe I don't know who was doing the
introductions also that probably they
didn't speak English and it goes the
other way too
like small tiny super super tiny small
amounts of time like a nanosecond you've
heard of a nanosecond but how it's the
amount of time it takes for light to
travel a foot to remember a billion
seconds ago with 1982 a billion
nanoseconds ago was by definition one
second to go and yet check this out the
fastest computer in the world can do 17
million calculations in one nanosecond
I'm not gonna get my mind around that
amazing to me because nobody really
internalizes that information but it
allows humanity to control the world and
to do so many amazing and cool things
for example all that math allowed us to
put the Kepler space telescope in orbit
where it told us there there between 15
and 30 billion
earth-like planets in our one galaxy and
there are more than 100 billion galaxies
in the observable universe and the
observable universes who knows how big
of a fraction of the actual universe
which may in fact be infinite Oh an
giving us yet more incomprehensible data
about how amazing our universe is not
designed to understand that stuff but we
are designed to want to understand it
which I may be wrong that that is the
most wonderful quality of human this is
going back to a previous conversation if
you're confused it may in fact be our
capacity and tendency to collaborate
with each other to make things bigger
than ourselves there have also been
people in the comments suggesting that
empathy is the most wonderful human
quality and that may also be true I just
kind of like the fact that there are so
many different underappreciated reasons
that humans are in the end pretty cool
nerdfighter pumpkin contest going well
plenty of time to continue your
submissions there have even been people
who have planned nerdfighter pumpkin
carving meetups
that's awesome additionally I've heard
that things are getting a little boring
at the dftba warehouse so every package
that it's not a poster gets one of these
with a hanger on it if you only have
posters in your order you won't get one
because we can't fit them into the
poster troops without ruining me you
will however get a free dftba wristband
I did these Hank were fishes while
watching a show called Call the Midwife
on Netflix you should watch that show in
super good cried like a thousand times
but it's very good if you're more in the
mood for a book this is a quick one by
Neil Gaiman the ocean at the end of the
lane which is beautiful and this is
losers in space by John Barnes is
excellent introduction to hard science
fiction if you've ever been interested
in that if you want to hear me ask some
of the smartest people I know when they
thought a million seconds ago was I made
a video about that it's on Hanks channel
I also participated in talk a youtube
channel where people talk about
interesting things this week on Talk
people were talking about online
education John I'll see you on Tuesday